Looking at these intervals that we said satisfy our inequality, the first one
tells us that x can be less than 4. That inequality is part of our solution.
However there's this other interval down here, that also has some acceptable
solutions. That's from x equals 9 and onward, so we can have x is less than 4,
or x is greater than or equal to 9. So you can see already, how useful and
really necessary using a table like this is, to come up with the solutions for
rational inequalities. It's not even always easy to tell whether or not your
intervals will contain or not contain the endpoints. So we just need to be
really careful and write out all of our steps. In interval notation, we can
express these intervals. The first one goes from negative infinity to 4, neither
endpoint being included. And as united, we write that with this capital U with
the interval 9 to infinity where 9 is included, and infinity, of course is not.